[Musique]
à 39 ans sans avoir exercé de mandat et
un an après la création de son mouvement
en marche
emmanuel macron accepte donc au second
tour de l'élection présidentielle
c'est les yeux rougis que le responsable
du mouvement dans les yvelines a pris
connaissance des résultats à 20 heures
moi je n'ai jamais fait de politique ma
vie ça n'a jamais été mon ambition
j'étais venu juste pour faire un bout de
parcours sur un projet citoyen la grande
marche et de la voilà il a poussé il
nous a donné confiance à nous donc
services it et c'est vraiment un plaisir
d'être là pas pourquoi pour ce moment là
vainqueur de ce premier tour au niveau
national vainqueur également dans les
yvelines emmanuel macron il devance
françois fillon d'un peu plus d'un point
emmanuel macron a su réconcilier
certains de droite certains de gauche il
a dit qu'il y avait des bonnes idées par
sont tous et moi ça me plaît beaucoup
comme état d'esprit moi j'attends déjà
sans l'attendre
depuis 50 ans depuis servan-schreiber et
le manifeste du parti radical
alors c'est incroyable aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est d'ores et déjà fait le
résultat du second
non bien sûr que non c'est jamais fait
les fachos ils ont en outre toujours ils
ont ils le restent toujours d une carte
dans la manche on sait pas ce qu'ils
peuvent sortir jusqu'au dernier moment
donc on ira se battre pour que la
victoire soit encore plus belle dans
certaines communes du département le
score du leader dans marche dépassent
les 30 % c'est le cas à maurepas
montigny le bretonneux ou voisins le
bretonneux
de quoi donner des sueurs froides aux
futurs adversaires du mouvement lors des
législatives et ravir les alliés
centristes du modem
alors on nous reproche certains certains
certaines valiance mais il faut que faut
pas que j'en oublie une chose c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'on a fait des amis on les
a faites autour d'un projet écrit et qui
nous paraissait aller dans le sens de
l'intérêt général on n'a jamais fait
d'alliance pour obtenir des postes
on a d'abord travaillé sur les projets
et ensuite on a vu comment on pouvait
faire ferrer aider les gens avec qui on
avait les alliances reste pour le moment
à l'emporter au second tour de la
présidentielle dans les yvelines les
responsables de gauche comme de droite
appellent majoritairement à le soutenir
à l'exception très nette de christine
boutin conseillère départementale qui
n'exclut pas un vote front national